aren't you ready Rock Paper Scissors
shoot
Darwin I probably did probably did in
this video we are going to build this
amazing Rock Paper Scissors game okay so
it's probably the sexiest Rock Paper
Scissors game you've ever seen in your
entire life right okay so without
further ado let's get started okay so
let's uh the first thing I'm gonna do is
go to my desktop and create a folder
called
rock paper scissors okay okay and let's
go inside that and we'll do touch index
dot HTML style CSS and app dot yes okay
and then we'll open this guy and Adam
alright so it's opened it's taken a
while these days I don't know why okay
cool
so let's close these guys down first and
let's open up index tab HTML CSS okay
all right so let's start coding so the
first thing we have is the first thing
we have is the header right so before
that let's get the skeleton odd the way
rock paper let's call it
rock-paper-scissors game or something
okay all right and let's open this guy
up and let's type in some gibberish sure
okay and open in browser okay so this is
this is the working version it is the
mountain working version okay so as you
can see our HTML file is working so
let's get rid of that okay so the first
thing we have is the header so let's uh
get that in a header tag not a div tag
so far we've done pretty much everything
in a div tag and that's okay but we want
to be more semantic okay so there's a
header
it's a header so we want to put it in a
header tag if it's a footer we want to
put it in a footer tag okay and then
later on we'll go over section two but
in this video we'll just wear those
we'll just do dibs
okay so header and then this one has in
each one rock-paper-scissors
okay okay let's go here refresh okay
that's how it looks hideous
right so we'll add the CSS later okay so
that's the header and then we have a div
for choices no no we
the scoreboard if so we'll give it a
class of scoreboard okay and then in our
scoreboard we have two badges right user
and computer it's on the edges but we'll
do that with CSS later but we have two
badges user and computer and then we
have the scores themselves yours your
starting numbers Seward zero okay so for
that we'll do
div of let's do let's see this one gonna
be user so we'll say user and for this
we'll give it a badge class of badge
we'll copy this paste and the next one
is going to be computer comp
okay now classes are cool because we can
share you know the same cells across
those two divs right with the same class
called badge
but we also want some IDs because we
want to uniquely position the user and
complete it right because the users on
the left hand and then the compass on
the right hand side so what we want to
do is say ID of let's say we give it a
idea of user label and then for this one
we'll give it an ID of comp computer
label okay all right so once we have
this let's go back and see how it looks
alright
nothing special okay so let's go and now
actually put the scores okay so now what
we do is add a span tag not a div tag
because they're in the same line spans
or inline elements there's our block
level elements okay so span will do zero
right it starts from zero later we'll
change it but for an angle I start with
zero and we want to give the first span
an ID of user score because the
left-hand side it's gonna be user right
and then we want to copy this and then
paste it okay so copy paste and we want
a colon in the middle and then we'll
call this computer score okay so now
refresh okay that's how it looks so far
okay alright let's keep moving
now we also need the message right so
now we need the paper covers rock
message so for that we'll create a div
here and we'll give it a class of I
don't know result
okay and then we'll say paragraph and
we'll say paper
well paper covers I can't type anymore
Rock you win okay cool and now let's go
back refresh that that's how it looks
okay now we want to add the choices
right these images okay so for that will
do div of class of choices and then
we'll have inner divs
okay well we'll have those images
wrapped inside each diff okay so we'll
do div and we'll say choice because it's
a bunch of choices so we'll have choice
for each one of them and then we'll do
image and right now I don't have images
in my directory as you can see I don't
have images right so what I'll do is
I'll pull it from my working directory
okay so from this folder and put it in
this folder copy it basically so what
I'll do is open hyper okay
and let's do this cool so now I have the
images here if you see here there that's
right these are all the images don't
worry about the da's store that's
nothing so I just copied it and paste it
in here okay so now what I can do is go
here image source and I can say images
slash it's called rock I think rock PNG
the first one is rock right okay and
then I'll copy this three times one time
two time okay and then this one is going
to be okay let me first refresh it okay
that's how it looks so far and now I'll
change this to paper refresh okay that
that's how it looks and then for the
third one we'll do scissors cool so now
we have the images and I think that's it
for them oh we also want to add some IDs
to each of these dips okay because later
on we want to be able to identify each
Rock Paper Scissors okay so what we do
is we just give it an ID of our okay we
don't need to say rock and then ID of P
and then I D of s
all right so that's it for the choices
so well let's go down hold on okay cool
all right now what do we have left we
have this message left right make your
move so let's do that
okay so let's P and all you do is let's
give it an ID of action message okay
action message sounds weird and then all
you do is make your move okay all right
so now let's go here refresh that's how
it looks like okay cool
so now let's actually add the styles
before I add any style so I want to make
sure I link it so link and we'll go here
and say styles dot CSS okay and now when
I write something in here let's do body
background too like red or something
okay
boom okay so it works okay so let's get
rid of it again as always let's start
off with the universal selector get rid
of the default margin and padding so
before I do that lets refresh here oh
let's get rid of it
okay refresh what okay margin:0
padding:0 and then we want box-sizing to
border-box okay and refresh that's it
right margins are gone okay
so the first thing we have to do is we
have to style this header so for that we
will say so let's go to index we have
header and we'll just say header okay
header background to be white right it's
white and what is it and for the text
color will do the header h1 header h1
color is what is that color let's get
that color hold on just a second let me
open up my color picking tool alright
and the color is let's see alright
that's the color okay so let's go here
refresh okay that's how it looks like
right now nothing special
and
also wanted text align this to Center
and then font-family to ASAP and then
back up is sensor okay so let's see if
that works
all right so that looks good and now we
also want some margins and padding's so
we'll do margin or padding of 20 pixels
on parent so there should be some
breathing room okay cool
and now as you can see here this the
entire body's background is this dark
bluish color right so for that we'll
just go right them buff this and we'll
say body background color to that color
so again let's grab that color boom boom
okay okay and actually this should be a
color for this one too okay cool
refresh and there it is right so now
it's looking a lot similar okay cool and
now we also want to let's see what do
you want to do oh sorry about that we
have not imported the ASAP font yet
right so you guys probably know how to
do it go to fonts google.com fonts
google.com and then go to ASAP right go
to a SAP click this plus button and then
it go come down here click on this go to
customize you want to get the you know
bold and medium you don't need to but
you know it's better if you have options
right so grab that go here to CSS go up
at the top paste it and boom right it's
done now if you go back here right right
now it looks like this I'm gonna refresh
and there it is right it's a little
different okay once we have this now we
have to style the scoreboard right okay
so what I'll do is let's go to
scoreboard okay because we gave it a
class of scoreboard right if you guys
remember we gave this div a class of
scoreboard so we'll do scoreboard I'll
first give it a border of three pixels
solid white okay let's see how it looks
okay that's how it looks right now it's
a hundred percent with
we don't want it to be hundred percent
with we want it to be less than that so
200 pixels or something okay refresh
okay that looks a lot better but now
this one's too close to the header right
so we want some space at the top and
bottom so for that we'll give it a
margin whoa margin of let's say 20
pixels at the top and bottom and then
Center it okay so we'll do enter and
there that's right it's centered and
then we have 20 pixels at the top and 20
pixels at the bottom okay
so that looks good now we also want to
change the text right the font color
okay so the font color is going to be
white fresh okay that looks good and we
also want to change the font size to be
40 pixels or forty-six pixels I think
there that's right so that looks
gigantic right now but we'll fix it in a
bit okay this user and comp is supposed
to be out of the box so for that before
I go into that let's also fix the border
radius because if you guys notice here
this one's kind of rounded this one's
not rounded so border radius is going to
be close to four pixels refresh okay
that's how it looks like cool
we'll also text-align that all this to
Center okay refresh all right that looks
good and we'll also give it some padding
of let's do 15 pixels on the top and
bottom and 20 pixels to the left and
right okay so there's some breathing
room now and we also want to change the
font family okay and let's do a SAP and
then sensor okay cool
refresh alright so that looks good but
now we also want to style these guys
okay these bad boys so for that we'll go
down here and if you guys remember we
called them badges right we gave them a
class of badges so we'll first style
that and then we'll go into user labeled
computer label okay so we'll go hold on
okay and we'll say dot badge background
is going to be let's get that background
color
Hey boom come on
why is it not working okay the color is
that guy okay
so background is that and we also want a
color to be white it's I think it's
already white but let's just make sure
okay that's how it looks like cool once
we have that now let's change the font
size because that's humongous so we'll
do font size to be 14 pixels okay and
then we'll give it a padding of two
pixels on the top and bottom and then
give some padding Center right and left
and we'll also give it a font family of
ASAP Sancerre okay fresh okay that's how
it looks like right okay so the styling
is good but now we need to take it we
need position the user to the left and
comp to the right right so what we do is
for that if you guys remember we gave
these IDs of user label and computer
labels so we'll do user label okay and
we'll do position of absolute again if
you guys don't know what positioning is
just go watch my like CSS videos okay
and then my previous project videos so
so if I do top:0 left:0 it will position
it to the browser's top left corner
there it is right but that's not what we
want we want a starting position to be
not the browser's top left corner but
the parent this scoreboards top left
corner okay so that it's easier to do
things and it's more consistent later
when we resize our screen okay so for
that we will have to give our scoreboard
which is our parent right here the
parent of this is the scoreboard so
we'll give this a position of something
other than static or inherit okay so
which is will just say relative all
right now refresh and it starts from the
scoreboards top-left corner right so
once we have this now we can position it
so I will say top of 30 pixels and then
we'll say left of
if you do positive we'll push it to push
it to the right we don't want to push it
to the right we want to push it to the
left right so refresh that's how it
looks like and if I do negative it looks
like this right so we want negative 25
let's see okay that looks good
and now we'll copy this and do the same
thing for you computer right so computer
and position absolute top 30 pixels and
then now we don't want to do left here
we can we can do left okay so if i
refresh that's how it looks like right
now right it's hiding behind the user is
hiding behind the computer so if I do
here instead of negative 25 - I do like
35 pixels right right now it's right
there but let's just do right okay
instead of left we'll just do right so
and then now it starts from the
right-hand side so if I do zero pixels
here it starts from the right-hand side
you see that right but we don't want to
do zero pixels and if we give it a
positive number it will just push it it
left if I do 10 pixels 20 pixels here
you see it pushes pushes it to the left
because it's the right property so we
want to say negative here okay negative
25 pixels or something okay maybe 35 no
30 okay so that looks pretty good all
right so now we are done with the
scoreboard now we want to get this thing
working okay so right now it's super
small and block so we'll change that and
we call it a dot result yes
so we'll say dot result and let's enter
a bunch let's bring it to the top okay
and now we'll say font size okay 40
pixels let's see how it looks okay that
looks pretty big all right and now we'll
do font color to be white
fresh we also want to text the line to
the center so we'll do dot result h1
text-align:center refresh okay
whoa why is it not working oh it's a P
tag it's not an h1 tag silly me
P tag okay that looks good and we will
also change the font family to ASAP
I should really put this at the top
instead of repeating font family every
single time because it's gonna be the
same font but it's okay alright so now
we have that I think we also need to
make it bold so we'll do want weight
weight of bold okay refresh alright that
looks good right yep
is the color a little bit different I
think it's a bit different online than
here why is that
let's I think the real color is this
right here okay so now let's see if that
works
okay there it is that looks a lot better
okay cool
alright now let's go over the actual
images okay for the choices the
rock-paper-scissors hand okay so we'll
do for that we'll go down here and index
dot HTML we called it choices and then
choice for each one of them okay so what
we have to do is we'll say the first
thing we'll do is that choice okay we'll
grab each one and it will do
display:inline-block okay so that will
make it horizontal cool and now we also
need to text align this so we'll do go
to the parent text-align:center are you
fresh okay that's how it looks like and
we also want some margins and because we
want some space at the top and bottom so
we'll do margin of what not margin left
margin of 50 pixels of top and bottom
and
we'll do zero okay so refresh alright
that's how it looks like I think we also
need a border so we'll do go to the
choice and will say border of four
pixels solid solid white okay so let's
see how it looks okay that looks pretty
good and now we also want to make it
circular right so for that it's pretty
simple
border radius and you always want it to
be the half of the width so right now
our width I don't know what the width is
here but the whole point is because you
don't know the width every single time
you want to do 50% okay because you
don't know the exact width in pixels I
mean we can find out but it's not that
practical okay you always want to use
percentages save refresh okay that looks
good
we also need some padding so we'll do
padding of 20 pixels let's see how it
looks I don't know okay that's too much
let's instead do 10 pixels okay that's a
lot better okay now we also want some
space in between each choice okay so for
that we'll give it a margin okay margin
of zero pixels to the top and bottom and
we'll do 15 pixels to the left and right
all right that looks good maybe 20 20
pixels okay it looks good right no
change
okay I think that's it for the images
but now we also want something to be
happening when we hover over you see
when we hover over it the background
changes right and cursor changes from
this pointer to like this hand tool
right so what we do is for that we go
down here we do dot choice hover okay on
hover we want the background to change
and also we want the cursor to change so
cursor we want to say pointer okay so
that's how you change it now when I go
over it okay that's the working version
let's go here refresh
there that's right it changes so we have
that working now let's also change the
background so we'll do background of
what's a color I don't know what the
color is let's say let's just do
something darker let's go here get that
and yeah let's do this okay all right
that looks good now that works but if
you notice something when when I hover
over it the color of the background
changes right away
right like instantly okay so let me give
it something else for now let's do red
or something okay right it changes
instantly we don't want that we want
something more smooth okay so we go here
and do transition and we can do all 0.3
s YZ okay so zero point three s 0.3
stands for how many seconds and as is
you know seconds so here if I do one s
you see it's pretty slow right but
that's not so natural it's way too slow
so what you want to do is 0.3 okay
that's what I use usually so now it's a
little bit more natural right so let's
go back and change this color back to
that so we'll do was it this quotient
know this color okay there it is okay
cool so now once we're done with that
let's make this make your move thing
work so that's called the action message
so we'll do action message and this
one's pretty simple like text align this
to center color is white font family
repeating for the hundred million time
all right that looks good we also want
it to be bold and a little bit bigger
font way to be bold and font size to be
20 pixels okay all right that looks good
hmm why is that going down oh okay if
you notice something here our make your
move is a little you know shifted
downwards a little bit more
and the original one so for that that's
happening because we have 50 pixels for
the choices you see that choices is this
whole thing this whole thing right and
this one has a margin top of 50 and
bottom of 50 so to fix this what we can
do is say just margin top here instead
of doing a margin like that so now it
only gives the margin top and now that's
too close but now we can add a margin
top here of 20 pixels or something all
right there it is
whoops were missing a period so let's
get that all right so that looks good
all right guys so that's it for
rock-paper-scissors HTML CSS part we're
going to do the JavaScript part okay so
I'm excited I'm sure you're excited so
what are we waiting for let's get into
it all right let's get into it so I have
my atom open in the right hand side and
the app open the left hand side this is
the working version so let's first take
a look at how the JavaScript is working
okay so I'm gonna refresh here and when
I click on the rock boom
Rock user loses to paper okay boom I
haven't fixed all of it yet but we'll
fix it okay it's supposed to be
subscript at all of it
so when you click on rock if you win it
goes hey you know you won and the user
score goes up and when you win the
border there's a green border it stays
there for like 300 milliseconds and then
it goes away okay if it's a draw then
it's it's the gray color so that's a
draw okay
and you probably notice the numbers
didn't change okay and if it's if you
lost then it'll give you a red border
border border border so okay you want
come on I can't lose I just can't lose
what okay cool there you go okay so
that's that's what happens when you
losing a so again all the other
values work as well all the other
buttons okay so let's go over to
index.html and before I write any
JavaScript let's make sure that we add
our JavaScript or link our JavaScript to
HTML okay and again we do that right
before the ending body tag yo okay app
digest
okay we have that and once we have this
we can just go to here and just do hello
let's see what that gives us refresh
okay let's first open this file okay
because this is the working version
that's the final version so we'll go to
here open and browser okay so this is
what we have right now right now nothing
worked you see when I click on it
nothing works because we haven't done
any of that yet so let's go to console
and let's make sure that our JavaScript
was working and it is workin cool so now
let's go to app digest let's collapse
that thing alright okay so the first
thing that I'm gonna do is cash the dumb
okay so then you're like tenzin what the
hell is cash the Dom but what does it
mean okay let me first do it and now
let's explain okay so so the first thing
we need are the actual scores right so
the actual variables so then what we can
do is say Const I'll call them user
score equals zero okay it's start it's
gonna start at zero Const computer score
equals zero okay now we're gonna update
this later depending on who wins and
stuff like that but we also need to show
it to the page right the document our
Dom so for that what we'll do is say
Const user score
LM or just say underscore span equals
document dot get element by ID user
score because we gave it an I gave it an
ID of user score right here if you
remember right there right and then
we're gonna do the same thing for a
computer score okay so let's copy that
pay
and I'm just gonna do computer score
here it's underscore span tag and this
is gonna be computer score let's go to
computer okay cool
so now you're wondering why the hell am
I doing this type this weird thing right
here okay so I this is my own style okay
you want to be consistent okay you don't
necessarily have to do this
so none to score I put it there to
clearly differentiate between normal
variables and then Dom variables okay so
these are Dom variables right so like
HTML the variables that store Dom
elements okay so I can clearly tell that
and also now when I put span because I
put those things in a span tag now I can
clearly tell that hey it's in a span tag
okay so that's just my way of doing
things okay you can do your own like you
don't have to put the underscore there
you can just do span tag here right but
that's just what I do okay so I think
it's a pretty good idea to do it this
way because you can tell okay it's a
it's a very Dom variable just because of
that underscore and then you know what
type of element it is like by span tag
div tag input tag right whatever it is
you just put that and then later on when
you're debugging and trying to look
through your HTML file it's gonna be so
much easier okay so I highly highly
recommend you do this okay all right now
let's get the scoreboard I'm gonna call
it scoreboard underscore div because I
stored that in a div tag okay it's a div
tag and then do document dot query
selector or yeah query selector and I'm
gonna say dot scoreboard okay
and that's because we called it
scoreboard right here okay we gave it a
class of scoreboard alright so once we
have this let's keep going let's get
this result div so I'll go here and say
result div div okay equals document dot
query selector dot
result and now let's also get the rock
paper and scissor buttons okay so for
those we're just gonna do const rock div
because i stored that in a div i think
yep yep and i'm gonna do document dot
get element by ID equals that's gonna be
our okay yep and copy paste and this is
gonna be paper div and p this is gonna
be PS and let's go here and do rock
paper scissors div okay
alright so now we have cached the dom
now let's go back to why we call it
caching the Dom okay so so caching the
Dom really means so caching in general
really means storing something for
future use okay so here what we're doing
is we're doing exactly the same thing
we're storing all of these things in
variables so that we can use it later
okay and it's not just for convenience
sake right it's a user score span it's a
lot like smaller like less to write then
document dot get element by ID user
score every single time right but
there's also a performance factor so
imagine every time we need to do
something we need to use that document
dot get element by ID user score we need
to get that reference point imagine I
was doing document dot get element by ID
every single time right when we do that
what we're doing is we're doing it we're
running a process and we're running that
process every single time we need to get
the reference to that element instead of
storing that in a variable once and then
we use that variable again because the
variable already has the reference to
that element okay
it's like imagine you're at a library
right and you're working on this
research paper and you need to get the
source for your research paper right you
need a lot of sources from this
particular book and now every time you
need that book you get away from that
you stand up you get away from the table
your desk and then you go to that shelf
find
book take it out read it find that
source and you're like hmm okay you
memorize it and then you put it back go
to your desk and then write this source
down and then when you need some other
sources again you go back to that book
and you Pete the same process again and
again right that's terrible
right very inefficient it's gonna take
you uterus okay to finish that paper
instead what you can do is go go find
that book
bring it place it down temporarily here
so that your book is right here on your
table your desk if you need a source so
then what you can do is go here okay I
need a source all right cool better yet
just leave the book open right so that's
like caching the Dom right instead of
doing document.getelementbyid IL
then it's just running that process one
time and then we have the reference
point in that variable so we're really
being efficient in terms of performance
and also convenience right it's really
convenient all right all right
so let's let's move forward all right so
now let's talk about what happens when
we click on those individual buttons
okay so when we click on rock what we
need to do is take that value okay it's
a rock and then compare it against a
computer's choice which is just going to
be a random choice between those three
options and then we compare those two
and then check who wins and then display
the result back on the Dom in the Dom
okay so I'm gonna first add some event
listeners to each button okay so we'll
do add add rock div dot add event
listener on a click I want to write a
function and that function is just gonna
do console dot log hey you clicked on
rock okay so let's see if this works
okay so refresh and inspect go to
console and now I'm gonna click on rock
okay there it is right
once you click on it it goes hey you
clicked on rock right now let's do the
same thing for these three okay so we'll
do 3d whoa let's do okay that's fine all
right so now we'll change this to paper
div we'll change that to paper and we'll
change this to scissors and come on and
we'll change this to scissors dip as
well okay so now refresh and now when I
click on rock it's gonna say hey you
clicked on rock when I click on paper is
gonna say hey you clicked on paper and
same thing for the scissors right there
it is
there you go okay so now that we have
those buttons working let's go further
okay so right now we're just console dot
logging we don't want a console dot log
okay we want some things happening okay
other than console dot log so what I'll
do is I will create a function called
game okay so I'm gonna pretend like I've
already created that some game and then
if the user clicks rocked if I'm gonna
provide an argument of rock okay R and
if the user clicks paper I'm gonna give
it an argument of P and then if the user
clicks scissors I'm gonna give it a give
it an argument of s all right so let's
get her the console dot log console dot
log and if i refresh right now nothing's
gonna happen it's gonna even error
because it says game it's not defined
okay because we don't have a function
defined for a game so let's do that
before I do that I'm actually gonna also
going to create a function called main
and then wrap all of this inside of that
okay let's do this and come down here
and then we will indent all of this
stuff okay cool and now to run this
we'll just do main up top here okay so
now if i refresh right it's still going
to give you that error because game is
not defined so then we can define that
game down here will actually just keep
it you know in a chronological order
so now let's define a function called
game and of course our game function is
going to take a user input right user
choice in this case so what we're saying
is again when somebody clicks on any of
these buttons take the value of those
buttons or whatever this RPS right
rock-paper-scissors and then compare it
against a computer choice and then get
the result back ok so here we're just
gonna say user choice choice user choice
choice twice twice user choice and let's
just say console dot log poop for now ok
so let's copy that and paste that a
couple times and we'll do plus and we'll
do user choice ok whatever it is so
choice what is happening come on give me
I don't know why it's not doing that but
let's do that all right so now let's see
what happens ok so now what I will do is
click on these buttons and it should
basically give me you know whatever I
pressed on it RPS this gives me our P as
it's kind of hiding in there but it's
there I promise you right there ok so
let's go back rock paper scissor right
so again it's just a function that we're
calling here right so when we call this
or it gets passed in here and then this
gets passed to this and you know how
functions work okay if you don't know
how functions work go watch my go take
my JavaScript course ok so go do that
alright so once we have this again we
don't want to console to a log so we
know that we have a user choice but now
we need a computer choice ok so to get a
random computer choice I'll just put
that in a separate function ok so I want
you guys to be comfortable with running
functions in other functions ok so what
we'll do is function and we'll say get
computer choice ok and we'll just do
this alright so what are what are the
options right what are the choices the
choices are R P s okay so we'll create
the choices Const choices equals no
right and we'll say whoa R P and s okay
so we have those and now to get a random
element from the choices array we do
that with the help of the built-in
object in JavaScript called math okay I
think we've used that in the unit
converter yeah I think so
so we can do things like math so here
I'll just do console dot log math dot
random okay so that's what you use math
dot random math is a built-in object in
JavaScript and random is a method that
exists in that math object okay so we
can use that so what this does is it
gives you a random number between 0 and
1 okay so you're like what what does
that help with anything
let's go into that in just a little bit
but let's first see what this does okay
so we'll do refresh and we have that
refresh refresh refresh refresh refresh
right it'll never go it'll never reach
one it'll always be between 0 and 1 okay
it will be a random number basically now
what we can do is say okay it's a number
between 0 and 1 is cool but in this case
we don't want that okay what we want is
a random number between 0 and 3 right 0
1 or 2 so then we can say okay if it's
if we get 1 we can just do a choice is 1
give me P if we get a random number
let's say 0 we can just do choices 0
which is our right so how we do that is
with times 3 okay you're like how does
that work how does that work
well let's let's see okay so refresh
refresh it'll never go over 3 you see
it'll always be like 0 1 or 2 you see
that I'm refreshing like a maniac right
now and how that works is let's do some
math here like zero point let's let's do
thing really low right between zero and
one which is like 0.01 or something so
let's do it 0.0001 times 3 well that's
just gonna give you something really
close to zero okay that makes sense and
now let's do something really close to 1
okay so let's do zero point 9 9 9 9 9
times 3 you see it never reaches 3 so
that's how we get random numbers between
0 & 3 if you want random numbers between
0 and 10 all we do is just put 10 there
that's it and now you get random numbers
between 0 and 10 okay it will never
reach 10 okay if you want it to reach 10
you can just do 11 there okay but again
this is not helpful to us again let me
change that back to 3 this is still not
helpful because we still can't do
choices you know zero point four right
it doesn't make sense okay so what we
need to do is actually round it down
okay make it a whole number instead of a
decimal number okay so for that we use
another method that exists in the math
object called math dot floor okay and
that's it
so now refresh look at that one one two
zero I'm refreshing like maniac again
command RRR you see it will always be a
random number between zero and three
right zero one or two so now what we can
do is instead of console about logging
this we can just store that in a
variable so we'll do random number
equals that okay cool
so we have that so far but now we don't
want the number we want the element so
we can just do return choices random
number okay so now let's run this
refresh refresh woah what is going on
here let's see it doesn't seem to be
working
oh we didn't consult
like this console dot log go here okay
darkness right refresh refresh refresh
refresh refresh refresh refresh refresh
refresh so it's going to be a random
it's gonna basically give you a random
element from that choices array okay so
let's get rid of that we know that our
function works so now we can move
forward in that game user choice
function okay so now we have user choice
now we need to get the computer choice
so we can just do const computer choice
choice equals get computer choice and
that's it okay so now let's do console
dot log computer choice here but we know
it works but let's just test it for the
hell of it let's go down here in game
and let's just do C or something it
doesn't really matter right now so see
that right it basically gives you the
random computer choice so again if I do
console dot log user choice let's do
user choice I don't know let's do
something like user choice that plus
yeah let's do that
and then let's go here get that guy put
it down here and we'll do this is going
to be computer choice maybe I'm going
overboard here but let's let's test it
okay there it is okay so again refresh
you see the computer choice always
changes but the user choice doesn't
change because we said C right so but if
we get rid of that and actually press on
the button now let's see what happens
right so now when I click on the our
rock it's always going the user choice
is always gonna be raw our and the
computer choice changes right it's gonna
be random and if I click on the hand
write rock paper then it's gonna be the
user choice is always going to be P and
then
your choice changes again and then if I
click on scissors it's gonna be s the
user choice is gonna be s and computer
is gonna change again okay all right so
once we have this now what we can say is
now we have to compare right now we do
if you know user picks Rock and computer
picks scissor then it's a win right if
the user picks paper and the computer
picks scissor then it's a loss right so
we have to do that so then now what we
can do is instead of using if statements
I'm going to use switch statement here
I'm gonna give you a quick intro here
but I highly recommend you check out the
documentation we can check the
documentation of switch so basically how
it works is let's say we have a variable
here called name okay and we'll just say
name is David all right and now usually
what we do is if name equals you know
David you know console dot log hello
right if we do and then else if name is
equal to pineapple and then then do
console dot log K right and then
depending on how the name changes it's
gonna either do hello or hey right if I
put right now it's gonna do hello
because name is David right but if I put
pine there console dot log hello it's
gonna run okay but switch statements how
it works is is very similar all you do
is switch and then the arguments so in
this case its name right and then what
you do is case and say if the case is
Apple : all I want you to do is say
hello console dot log or console ball
log this is Apple and then break and
then all you do is say case pine then I
want you to do console dot log something
else like whatever and then
whoa and then break here right so this
is how switch statements work okay
very similar you can do everything that
you can do it's do with switch
statements with if statements and vice
versa but in some cases switch
statements make things a lot easier than
you know if statements so here what we
can do is say switch user choice plus
computer choice okay
so let's first take care of all the
cases all the situations when the user
wins okay so the user will win if the
user choice is our and rock and the
computer choice is paper yep and if the
user choice is paper and the computer
choice is rock and if the computer
choice user choice is scissors and the
computer choice is rock no paper yeah
yeah our PPR SP okay in those cases what
we want to do is say console.log user
wins okay and then break you always need
to put that break or else it'll keep
going to the bottom we don't want that
so we'll also do case so now we'll take
care of when the user loses so if the
user picks some rock and the computer
picks what wins with a pug paper okay
and user picks rock paper and computer
picks scissors and rock scissors and
computer picks rock okay in those cases
we just want to say console.log computer
wins okay or user loses but just keep
things very consistent loses
all right and break again okay now let's
do the same thing for the rest so we'll
do five while I paste okay cool and now
for the case the last one is if the if
they're both equal right so we can just
do our R this one's simple right RP RS
ok cool so our RP p SS in those cases is
just its draw okay all right so that's
it so now let's see what happens when we
click on these buttons all right so I'm
gonna refresh here nothing's there click
on rock one time whoa nothing happened
okay let's hold on let's do it again
click done Rock okay cool I don't know
what what happened there click on rock
okay it's what it works user wins user
wins I'm click keep clicking it's a draw
it's a wins wins
I'm never losing I think there's
something wrong there
there's something wrong there I think
something's wrong there let's see oh my
god silly me okay so here it's not
supposed to be RP it's supposed to be
rock and scissors right if computer as
user picks rock and computer pick
scissors user still wins okay so I knew
something was wrong there but I was just
so gone earlier okay so let's refresh
and see if it works okay so now we have
losses some losses some wins and some
draw okay which is which makes sense so
if I click on the hand icon paper we
have some wins some losses and some
drops same thing for the scissors okay
so we know that our game function works
okay but now it's just an ax console dot
log right it's not showing anything up
there on the page it's not doing
anything right which is not what we want
all right so for this what we can do is
we can again separately create different
functions for winning losing and draw
okay we never want to put
Jemm all the logic and one function
never ever okay because then later on
it's it's hard to read it's hard to
debug it's hard to work with other
people it's just bad okay so instead of
logging winds and stuff like that but
we'll do is we'll say winds create a
function called winds okay
so right now we're just pretending that
we've already created a function called
winds okay so when the user wins
actually let's do win okay and when the
user wins I want to do something with
the wind function okay and I also want
to do when the user loses I want to do
lose and then when the user draws it's
when it's draw I just wanted to draw
okay now I can go up top here and do
those functions again so let's do
function when and then that just console
dot log win for now okay I just want to
again test it right away okay don't move
forward I mean this is like we know this
is gonna work but I'm just trying to
prove a point okay so let's do why paste
paste okay let's go here alright cool so
now if for this one lose come on lose
and this is gonna be lost and go down
here this is gonna be traW and we'll
just say draw okay all right so now
let's see what happens okay so it's
still working so again let's go back and
start working
okay so right now we have win and now
when we win we want to show well what do
we want to do first we want to first
increase the users score right so the
first thing we do is we go up we have
user score and computer score right so
what we can do is say user score user
score plus plus that's it all right and
let's go to the lost I mean it's it's
this is not really really realistic
usually you don't like work in three
functions functions at once right but
I'm just showing you here you can just
do like computer score plus plus here
okay but we're not gonna do that
we're just will work on this function
and then work on this and then work on
draw okay so one at a time all right so
user score plus plus and now let's just
show you two score okay let's see what
it is okay and let's wait for it let me
hold on let's do console dot log it's a
win okay all right so now refresh and
let's see what happens okay the draw
let's keep clicking draw draw draw draw
okay so now it's saying signage constant
okay so what's happening right now it's
saying you're trying to change the a
constant variable okay this Const so
what we do is instead of constant we can
either use let or bar okay we should we
should be okay using blood here okay so
we can just use let alright so now let's
go back here and do the same thing draw
you see that when you when you when we
win the score went up by one and it's a
1 now again if I keep clicking you see
whenever we win it goes up holy crap we
just won like seven at once or something
like eight eight times and grow that's
crazy so let's go back and instead of
win here
I don't want win I don't want to console
about log users score what I want is I
want to show it on the page so what we
do is instead of console logging we just
go user score span okay because that's
the element right because we're saying
you two get element by ID user score and
that's the span tag this span tag right
here okay so let's go back and all we do
is use your score span dot innerhtml
equals user score that's it
all right so now and then we can also do
the computer score right so we'll also
update the computer score even though
right now since we only have the window
it's not gonna the computer score is
going to remain the same
so let's do equals computer score okay
all right so now let's keep clicking you
see that when the user wins the score
goes up right again it says assignment
two constant variable o innerhtml
all right not in our text HTML okay
refresh and that should be okay now okay
so every time we win the user score goes
up okay so once we have the score now we
need to actually display the message
that says paper beats rock or whatever
right and for that we can't do that yet
okay and that's because we don't have
anything that says you know any
reference in our win function right we
have that in our game function but not
in our win function okay so what we can
do is give it some parameters here and
say user choice and computer choice okay
or you can just say user computer
doesn't really matter what you call it
okay a B you can call it anything you
want okay I'm just gonna call it user
choice computer choice okay and down
here again just to just so you guys
don't get confused so I'll just do user
computer for now okay and then down here
what we can say is when when you
actually run the function right this is
defining a function but when you
actually run the function pass in
whatever you whatever the user choice
and computer choice is okay so as the
adds an argument here I'll just do user
choice and then computer choice okay and
then I do that for all of the other ones
so user choice and computer choice and
we'll define they lose and draw function
in a bit so user choice and computer
choice okay and now let's do console dot
log user choice not user choice let's
just do user because remember we changed
it so that you guys don't get confused
computer and refresh and now you see
it's gonna be Rs every single time
because
it's always gonna be a win right because
this is a win function it only takes
here win right it's not gonna take care
of when you lose and draw okay so that's
what happens but we don't want that what
we want is we don't want to console that
log we want to show it on the page so
what we do is get the result if result
div dot innerhtml and say you know user
choice + beats + computer choice okay
and then we'll say plus you win okay so
let's see if this works so let's wait
for when we when user choice is not
defined why is it that okay we called a
user and computer I can't I keep
forgetting that so we'll just call it
user choice okay that just makes more
sense
so we'll do user choice computer choice
okay all right I don't know why it's
doing that right now
oh okay so when we actually got the
reference to that element we said
document dot query selector dot result
okay and if we take a look at our index
dot HTML we stored that not in the
result I mean we did but it's inside of
a P tag inside of the result okay so
here really what we want to say with P
okay get the P tag get the paragraph tag
inside of the result so now when we
actually change this it's gonna be a
paragraph okay so here we should really
call this not div but P all right so
let's go down here and where is the what
do we use the result P anywhere else
let's hope not okay and let's go here
and let's call it P and this should work
and now let's see when we win there does
our beats s you win right
however our beats s is not so readable
okay our beats s not so readable we want
it to be human readable okay so what we
can do is convert this to rock and this
to scissors okay and we'll create
another functions for those okay for
those things so in this case a function
had not functions okay
function and we'll call it convert to
word or something all right and it'll
take in a letter and then we just do if
the letter is equal to R just return
rock if the letter is equal to P paper
return paper and if those two are not
met then just return scissors okay okay
so now here what we can do is just say
convert to word and go down here as well
convert to word okay and refresh you see
that right now it says paper covers rock
because we're not winning it's a draw
draw but then when you win rock beats
scissors okay you win okay so that works
but now while we're at it I also want to
introduce you guys to some es6 ok so
right now this is this is cs5 right here
right when you have to combine a
variable with a string all you do is
plus okay which is cool but not so cool
okay so in yes 6 there's something
called template strings and all you do
is with the backticks okay and if you
don't know what where the back take is
you can google that but on a mac it's on
the top left corner right below the
escape button okay and windows is
probably there but if it's not just look
it up on your keyboard you should be
able to find it okay and then all you do
is wrap the
backtick as well and that's it okay so
now you can get rid of the pluses and
and the quotes so let's do that get rid
of that get rid of that and let's get
rid of the pluses there you win okay
that's good let's get rid of the quotes
at the end there and now to convert to
word user choice it's not a string right
right now if I display this I said it's
just gonna display them as strings which
is not cool right that's what right
that's not cool so what we do is if it's
a variable in this case it's gonna you
know return it's a function so we just
dude dollar sign and wrap that with
curly brace okay so that's all it is
okay and then we do the same thing with
convert and there you go
all right paper covers rock you win
let's keep going rock beats scissors
right now there's it's not gonna say
convert to word user choice you see
right so this is a lot more readable
okay so now that we have the basic
functionality of the win function
working now that we have that we can
move on and just copy this okay copy
this and just paste it right here okay
so we can just say actually before that
let's work on one more thing before we
move on okay so right now we have rock
beats scissors but it's still like not
clear who's winning who right you can
see your numbers going up but uh you
can't really tell who's who's who picked
rock and who picked scissors okay you
can kind of you know calculate that
because if you pick a rock of course
you're the one who picked rock but hey
let's keep let's make that super clear
so what we can do is right here we can
just add something and we'll just say we
can just sum do something like you know
um let's do let's just do
is always gonna be user right user and
this is always going to be computer comp
okay this is cool like that's cool but
it's a little too long okay I don't want
to I don't want to make that and it's it
just doesn't look good okay I thought
about doing it you know make like
putting a picture somewhere here right
that'd be pretty cool but I didn't I
wanted to keep it keep things simple
okay so here what we can do is say Const
do small word or small user word yeah
small user word sure or equals user and
just do dot font size okay that's how
you control the font size okay and also
I also did this so that I can expose you
to these little you know string methods
in JavaScript okay so user dot font size
will do three it will make it super
small and then will superscript that
okay so now what we can do is make the
same thing and do comp and then we'll do
font size of three and superscript that
as well so superscript is basically let
me let me remove that for now and let's
first whoa let's first let's go up up
okay so now instead of user here we just
put that in a curly brace okay like that
and then do small user word and then
we'll say come down here and do the same
thing with this guy so we'll do small
cop word wait I don't think I called it
comp word okay let's go up yep for this
one it's gonna be small comp word okay
and this is gonna be com font size three
so let's see how it looks now come on
you see that so that's how it looks
right now but right now it's on the same
line so what I want to do is on a
superscript
or subscript I think subscript work
would work better so subscript
superscript would do this let's do dots
su p dot su p okay and these methods
exist on the string object in JavaScript
it's built into JavaScript so and if you
put s you be it's gonna move that down
or be be fresh there that's okay so this
looks a lot nicer than just that's okay
again if you guys prefer the brackets
it's okay doesn't the parentheses it's
okay you get you guys can user okay
bracket parentheses you parentheses see
just use that if that's easier to
understand okay so alright so we have
the basic functionality working so what
I want to do is I just want to copy all
of this okay so I'll just do copy and
paste okay because this functionality is
gonna be the same thing right
and let's do this and let's paste that
as well
okay so we have that and let's indent
that way what okay so we indented that
alright so now let's take care of lose
then it will go into draw okay
so right now when we lose we don't want
the user score to go up when you want
the computer score to go go up right and
we don't want let's see we don't we want
to show this right you just spanda inner
HTML equals that that is good that is
good that is good and then in the result
P what we want to say is do losses to
okay
losses to computer you lost and not not
that okay hold on okay not that and
that's it so now when we lose it should
do that too let's let's add an approved
air okay
okay let's do that
refresh okay well user choices not
defined what's going on let's see it
says app j s line 38 user choices not oh
okay you see that we didn't define it
here okay user choice computer choice
all right so refresh and you win let's
see what happens you lost okay we have a
poop that's a happy poop he's happy you
can make it even we lose okay cool
so we have that and you can see that the
computer score goes up when we lose you
see whenever we lose the computer score
goes up okay and when it's draw nothing
happens right now because we need to
again coat that okay okay so we have
done that and now let's go to the draw
and here we don't do user score plus
plus or do any plus plus because let's
draw nobody goes up okay you can like
make both of their score go up but that
just doesn't make sense so we'll just do
those two and we don't need to do these
right yeah we don't need to do that and
or do B let's see yeah we don't need to
do any of that
put a draw for draw we can just keep
yeah we can just keep that the same so
it's just like equals we'll just say
equals and we'll do it's a draw okay and
what emoji should I use boring now I
don't know let's just use Apple let's
just not use anything
okay okay user choice is not define
again in our draw we got it define that
so choice user computer choice refresh
and look at that so now when we win is
gonna say win see and when we lose it's
gonna say lost right and when we do draw
its plot equals rock and it's a draw
okay all right so that's pretty much it
in terms of the main logic of our app
all right now let's add some finishing
touches and do the little things okay
you know what they say they say the
difference between the good and the
great is that little extra okay that
little extra I don't know who said it
but the first time I heard it I mean and
that's why I still suck okay let's keep
going so if you notice on the working
app refresh I'm gonna wipe that piece
there but it doesn't matter so when I
click on it you see if it's a draw it's
that gray it adds that gray border
animates it and goes away right if I
lose that happens and if I win let's see
if I went there you go right the green
thing called border appears so for that
what we can do is in our win lose and
draw functions we can add some things to
it okay so what we do I said we can
first work with the win okay so we'll do
is go here
and let's go to a working app right now
if i refresh nothing happens right I
mean the message pops up everything else
works but animations not there okay so
for that what we can do is add a class
to each of them okay so when the user
wins and if we click this guy it should
add a class with some styles to this div
okay so how we do that is first we have
to make some styles I mean some classes
right in our style style CSS and this is
JavaScript video but I left this off for
JavaScript because I felt like this had
more to do with JavaScript and CSS okay
so here we can do green glow okay so
when the user
wins we want some green border to appear
so I'll do border four pixels solid and
let's do four d CC 7d okay and then
we'll get a box shadow okay box shadow
of zero zero four pixels or ten pixels
and we'll give it a color a darker green
color
let's do three 1b for three a for this
okay and now let's do the same for red
glow okay red glow and we do something
similar so let's grab that and in this
case we want to add a color of something
reddish let's do F c-121 B and for the
box shadow color let's do D zero one one
one five okay and now let's repeat the
same process for for the gray color so
we'll do gray glow and we'll do
something great for 6 4 6 4 7
and for this one we'll do two five to
nine to be more darker okay that looks
good and if you don't know how the Box
shadow works this is the horizontal
vertical offset and then you have the
blur and the color okay that's all it is
and then you can you can have an
optional value here for spread humm how
far your shadow should go but again you
can look that up it's super simple it's
not that hard so now let's go to the
JavaScript part and here now that we
have those classes what we can do is say
when the user wins okay when the user
wins what I what we want to do is add a
class of green glow to whichever div the
user clicked on okay if the user clicked
on the rock div it should give it should
give that octave a class of green glow
okay and that's gonna give that board
Green okay so now for that what we can
do is say document dot get element by ID
of our right but our is a hard-coded
letter right or argument and that's not
what we want because then it will only
give that green color only if we click
on the rock what what if we won when we
click on the paper right it's not gonna
do that
we'll have to hard code everything so
that's not what we want to do here what
we want to do is get the user choice
okay and again user choice here is
whatever user clicks on it and then it's
either you know it basically is either R
P or s okay it's one letter and
depending on what the user clicked on
okay so we do document dot get element
by ID user choice dot class list
classless is a method that exists in the
DOM and with JavaScript when you do that
when you what it gives you is an array
of all the classes on that specific
element okay and now what we do is on
that array we just do a dot add and then
add our class so then we can just say
dot green glow here okay and that's it
so now let's see what happens when we
click something and if we win let's see
what happens okay refresh click click
click let's see if I win it's winning
but it's not doing that let's see what
why that is oh I'm not supposed to put
the period there because we know it's
gonna be a class okay um so we don't
need to put that there
okay and there it is so the border here
is not working okay so the glow is
working the box shadow is working but
the border is not working okay so it's
still white and I think there's some CSS
conflicts so I'm not gonna look through
everything and try to fix it what I will
do is I will just put that important
flag okay maybe we can just move all
this down at the very bottom and that
should fix it let's try that first
because putting the important flag is
never a good idea
okay so we'll go down all the way down
and put it a cure okay let's see if that
makes a difference okay let's go here
refresh and there it is okay so we
didn't have to put that important flag
okay cool let's also make sure it works
on paper and scissors okay it works on
all of them if we win clicking on any of
those buttons it will add a border of
green however it's still green right
it's not supposed to be green if you go
here right if we win it just goes back
to white right it's it has that little
animation so how do we do that right so
we do that by using something called a
set timeout function in JavaScript okay
and we can do this thing with CSS but I
just wanted to do this with JavaScript
so I can introduce you guys to set
timeout maybe we've done that with the
digital clock I think we use set in a
roll there but yeah let's do that
timeout okay
so let's go over what's that timeout
does so here let me just run it in the
out in the global scope let's do set
timeout and that timeout takes two
arguments okay it's gonna taking a
function and let's do function and let's
just say console dot log hello okay and
the second argument it takes is the time
in milliseconds of how long you should
wait before you perform that first
argument first function okay so if I do
3,000 milliseconds here which is three
seconds it will wait if I run this okay
it will wait three seconds and then it
will say hello okay so if i refresh here
let's count zero one two boom there it
is right if I do one second it should
happen in a second refresh one there it
is right so that's how that works
so let's comment that out let's not
comment that let's get rid of it it's
pretty simple
maybe let's undo and actually grab it so
then we can just use that in our
function there
and there you go okay so instead of
console dot log in here what we need to
do is run something else okay and what
we do here is so we add it a class
called green glow right when we clicked
on that div when we won but now right
after that what we need to say is hey
wait for three seconds or one second or
however many seconds and then remove
that class okay so let's do that so that
we can just do document dot get element
by ID of user choice again and then dot
class list dot remove green glow okay
and now you can see it happening if I go
to let's refresh and let's go to here
inspect and let me drag this to the
right a little bit and let's go look at
all these dips okay let's see what
happens when I win okay let me refresh
again I should have done that okay there
it is
alright so I'm gonna click on this I
lost draw no there it is right so it it
was there for a second and then it went
away okay again again let's come on let
me win there you go right it asks that
green glow class and then it removes
that okay again again it works on the
paper and scissors to like come on win
there you go stays there goes away okay
so right now it's not so natural because
if you notice here come on let me win
once please no no no no no no no what
okay you see it's it takes a little too
long for it to go away so what we should
do is make that like three hundred
milliseconds okay which i think is a
little bit more natural so now if I win
here I don't have look with paper lists
to go with Rock there you go right it's
a little bit more more natural it's
faster okay so now we can just copy and
taste this and also you can you can
probably you know put this in a variable
because we're using it twice here right
let's be efficient let's just do it okay
let's just do it
so we'll just go up top here and since
these are variables we should probably
move this up top here okay and let's
just do
constant we'll just call it user choice
diff let's go here and we'll call it
document dot get element by ID user
choice okay and now we can replace this
whole thing with user choice diff okay
and let's do the same thing with this
guy here user choice div okay that looks
good and now we can just copy this two
more times
let's go here copy that and here instead
of green glow what we want is red glow
right because we lost and let's go here
as well red glow and let's go down and
for that we can just do paste whoa let's
get that okay and here let's just do
gray glow let's go up top gray low we'll
have to get that variable as well so
copy let's just get to the top paste
paste and let's move this to the top as
well alright so that looks good let's
refresh her let's see one gray lost okay
this seems to be working let's go to the
paper gray gray lost one lost lost gray
come on
did I win can can I please win
I swear okay there you go it's working
gray lost
okay so lost and gray works okay winning
works too okay alright so that works now
I want to do one last thing before I
call it a day okay so let's go here to
our function and let's yes 6fi it
okay so let's instead of doing it the
es5 version here instead in this inner
function in es6 what you do is get rid
of this function name and then add an
arrow okay and then if it's just a
one-liner here this user choice div
class list is just one line right so for
that we can just get rid of this curly
brace okay and now let's get rid of it
and this should still be working so
let's go to red glow and see if it works
let's see when we lose what happens come
on can I have lose now there it is right
it still works so we can do the same
thing for all of this so let's get rid
of that add an arrow and since it's one
line we can just get rid of this and get
rid of that cool and now let's go to the
wind section and let's do the same thing
get rid of these two let's go and get
rid of that and at the arrow okay
refresh it's still working
whoa what happened Oh get rid of that
okay there it is it still works
cool everything looks good and I think
we have some es5 yep yes five code here
so we'll also fix these all right so
here again we can just do the same thing
just go here at the arrow get rid of
this this get rid of this this this and
that's it and let's do the same thing
here get rid of that add an arrow whoa
and let's pull these up get rid of that
get rid of these two get rid of these
two alright and
again let's do the same thing okay okay
get that that and that's it right I
think that's it okay so let's make sure
it's working before anything all right
this is working all the clicks are
working and looks good let me delete the
lines here wow this is looking very very
sexy okay um I think that's it alright
guys so that's it for
rock-paper-scissors if you have any
questions leave it in the comment
section below peace out dude